the ongoing investigation that started
yesterday in the crash of a king air
super king air 350 I and we have a
picture of it here this is an exemplar
aircraft maximum seating capacity is 11
seats we know from our investigation so
far that there were 10 people on board
so pretty much a full load speed on the
aircraft maximum speed 312 knots the
take-off distance under what they
consider standard conditions is 3,300
feet that means the aircraft is fully
loaded and that's done at sea level and
at what we call standard temperature
which is 59 degrees that's not how it
usually is here in Dallas in the
summertime so the take-off distance is
going to be a bit longer the maximum
range on the aircraft is about 1,800
miles and what I put on the bottom there
is the distance from Addison to st.
Petersburg which is where the flight was
filed to is approximately 800 nautical
miles if you go directly air traffic
control never lets you go directly but
that kind of gives you a bit of an idea
there were some questions yesterday
about the tail number of the airplane
and here's what we know right now it was
in the process of being changed so I'm
going to give you both tail numbers they
all start with an N or November that's
the international identification for US
based aircraft so the tail number was
November 5 3 4 F F or Foxtrot Foxtrot
November 5 3 4 Foxtrot Foxtrot it was in
the process of being changed according
to the FAA records to November 5 1 1
echo Foxtrot November 5 1 1 echo Foxtrot
the aircraft ownership based on again
FAA records was eee operations LLC ee
operations LLC at this point it looks as
if the flight was considered part 91
which is personal flight that means that
you're not allowed to charge for
passengers on board FAA is continuing to
look at that area last night around
10:30 our team recovered the cockpit
voice recorder and it is being
downloaded now in the Washington DC
laboratory of the NTSB we don't know
exactly what's on the recorder but what
the recorders do the CVR as we refer to
them will capture external
communications on the aircraft between
the crew and air traffic control and of
particular interest to us is the
internal cockpit conversation between
the pilot and the copilot so we don't
know exactly what's on that but we'll
hope to have an update on that possibly
by tomorrow the other thing we may be
able to get out of and I stress may is
that there may be some background noise
that is picked up by the CVR which will
give us a little better situated on with
the airplane itself we've gotten some
interviews so far I think two interviews
and we have witnesses and we expect to
have some more coming forward
dr. Rhodey could you tell us a little
bit about the structure situation
absolutely the team was able to identify
through the support of our drone team
that all four corners of the airplane
arrived at the accident scene what that
means is the external right wing the
external left wing the tail feathers or
the empanadas the airplane and the nose
of the airplane
remnants of all of those have been
positively identified at the scene which
leads us to believe that all of the
airplanes so everything in between those
four external points also arrived at the
accident scene and we're involved in the
impact sequence thank you
we're looking at the air traffic control
radar data at this point
and their communications what we know at
this point is the communication seemed
to be completely normal in other words
the pilots were cleared for takeoff they
acknowledged takeoff and at this point
we are not aware of any further
communication between the crew and air
traffic control again the CVR
will give us more data as that gets
downloaded but you talked a little bit
about systems the team was able to
identify that the landing gear was down
at the time of the impact too
unfortunately due to the extensive
post-impact fire and damage incurred
during the impact sequence other systems
are virtually destroyed and at this time
we do not believe we'll be able to
establish positive conditions for other
systems and flight controls
the FAA is now working on looking for
the maintenance records of the aircraft
anytime there's any maintenance done on
an airplane it will be documented to by
a certificated mechanic these airplanes
are required to undergo an annual
inspection this airplane was about two
years old so it would have gone through
at least two annual inspections at this
point any modifications that were made
to the aircraft will also be documented
the FAA is also looking at the pilot
records as we speak and we'll look at
their certification and any training
that they have had as we mentioned
yesterday this aircraft requires a type
rating which means that the pilots must
have specific training in the king air
350 it's a single pilot aircraft so it
can be flown by just one pilot we know
that there are there were two
crewmembers on board anything more you
want to say about drones so we had a
drone team on scene today that was able
to document the external and internal
damage to the hangar that was impacted
during the accident sequence in addition
to doing aerial documentation of the
wreckage both inside and outside of the
hangar this morning we had an
organizational meeting to establish the
parties of the investigation so these
are the people who have the technical
background frequently the manufacturer
to give us more detail about the
aircraft itself they do not assist in
the analysis part or in the
determination of probable cause they
only help us to determine what was going
on with that particular part of the
airplane so the parties to the
investigation include the FAA as I've
already mentioned Textron aviation who
was the manufacturer of the airplane
hartzell propeller who made the
propellers the national air traffic
controllers association and pratt &
whitney canada who made the engines
dr.rudi would you tell
a little more about presently the Pratt
& Whitney engines are manufactured in
Canada through ICAO annex 13 the
Transportation Safety Board of Canada is
an accredited representative to our
investigation and Pratt & Whitney Canada
works through the Transportation Safety
Board of Canada as a technical liaison
to our investigation we've got some
photos now we'd like to share with you
and these will be released at about 4:30
central Daylight Time on WWI NTSB gov so
let's go through a couple of those here
you see a drone shot of the
was anything
this is the looking in the other
direction
and you can see some debris on the top
of the hanger which we will at some
point need to recover it's not safe to
go up there right now this is a view
inside the hangar looking from the front
we have a falcon 50 jet we mentioned a
last evening that was heavily damaged by
the fire and there was a helicopter
which is not shown helped to suppress
the fire I'll now take your questions
please raise your hand I'll call on you
and then give us your affiliation and
your name and we'll go from there
yes ma'am
did we recover a black box and is it a
voice recorder is it something else this
is a cockpit voice recorder this
particular one is encased in a black box
so you could call it black box most of
them are orange
but this only records voice it does not
record the flight characteristics of the
aircraft this airplane was not equipped
with a flight data recorder sir
is the NTSB looking at similarities
between this crash and the king air
crash in Honolulu I don't think we're in
the position quite yet to do that they
are different types of aircraft and we
take each accident on its own obviously
at some point there might be a further
analysis of various makes and models but
these are two completely different
models doctor rody do you have anything
more to add on that okay yes ma'am the
information we have in the video that we
saw was that the airplane was airborne
so the airplane had gotten airborne and
then veered to the left of the runway
and then started to roll to the left and
it was in the process of rolling when it
collided with the hangar yes sir
[Music]
did the aircraft roll completely upside
down and is weight considered a factor I
think we're going to have to study a
little bit more about exactly what the
angle of the aircraft was we just we
have just the preliminary video doctor
rody you want to talk a little bit more
about that so we'll be pulling in a
performance group that will be working
primarily back in Washington DC and they
will be reviewing all of the video that
is coming in to us taking into
consideration the frame rates and
location where the different videos were
taken and seeing if they can ascertain
greater details to establish how fast
and how far the aircraft rolled during
the accident sequence and then during
the impact sequence that's a good
question but we can't quite yet
determine exactly where we are so that
but that will be looked at very very
closely the other question regarding
weight that's a work in progress so we
will we will be looking at that yes sir
[Music]